[Music]
when we learned that the gold iPhone 5s
had already sold out we were frankly
surprised we didn't anticipate that kind
of demand for just one color of the
phone and so we've increased production
on the gold iPhone and we should have
more available in just a matter of weeks
weeks rome wasn't built in weeks it was
built right now you want iPhone gold I
get your iPhone gold the internal
architecture of the silver and gray
phones is identical to the gold it's the
same exact phone
go to space type uncle faster bigger
louder quieter smaller sexier wetter
taller
what business deal it's just best simply
place your order at an Apple store and
your gold iPhone will be shipped to you
as soon as it's available
no no no no no Rafi gotcha here's what
you do go to your local Apple Store not
in front but in back don't talk to
geniuses talk to one of my nephews there
are called tank tops and gold sneakers
and eBay they charge you triple but for
you you only paid double its price like
you there's no reason to pay double just
go to the website
yeah yeah just go to the website ww only
to double use that give me confirm now
okay I got you slash thanks Robbie you
the man under store you got it man
backslash gobies banks dot yes hashtag
[Applause]